foreign
there are few figures as recognizable as
the Grim Reaper when it comes to the
idea of death but where did this
skeletal figure shrouded in dark robes
carrying a scythe even come from why is
this the image so many of us associate
with death what better way to find out
than by examining the history of the
Grim Reaper and The Many deities of
death from all around the world
today's video has been made possible by
wandrium for those who have been around
you will know that I've been using one
dream for several years now and I think
it's a great educational tool and
resource for those who are new wandrium
has joined forces with a Great Courses
plus to create a bigger better and more
immersive educational experience than
before there are thousands of lectures
documentaries courses and videos for
everyone the ever-growing library means
there are always new topics whether
you're looking for a quick how-to or
just some mind-blowing facts you can
learn at the pace that suits you best in
the comfort of your own home on pretty
much any device one dream have launched
a new series titled traveling the Roman
Empire there are all sorts of mentions
of Cults and deities that were worshiped
in ancient Rome The Cult of mithras
being one I was very happy to learn more
about the show doesn't just cover Roman
architecture engineering and history
within Italy it covers numerous other
countries that were occupied by the
Roman Empire spanning across Eastern
Europe the Middle East and Africa the
show is a fascinating watch for anyone
with an interest in history or ancient
Rome if you'd like to try one dream for
yourself you can visit wondrium.com
mythology or you can use my link in the
description to start your free trial
today
when we imagine the Grim Reaper we often
see him as a man however it was very
common in numerous parts of the world
for death to also be personified as a
woman in Spanish Italian and
french-speaking countries it's not
uncommon to see literature and art
depicting these Reapers as female the
images themselves vary wildly from
beautiful and ugly to young and old in
England and Germany during the Middle
Ages death was personified as an
animated skeleton with a scythe which
would collect the souls of the dying and
those who had already passed in Poland
death is also a skeletal figure however
it takes the form of a female and so
instead of the black robes we associate
with the Grim Reaper death here is an
elderly woman in white rose
the term Grim Reaper first appeared in
English in 1847 in the book titled the
circle of human life which was
translated from the previous German
version by August otherwise known as the
tunes of Christian devotion we know the
Grim Reaper is just one of the many
personifications of death but how did
his image become so recognizable for
that we have to go back to the 14th
century when one third of Europe's
population and a tenth of the global
population had fallen victim to the
plague an epidemic many consider to be
one of the worst we've ever seen with so
much death and Medicine being nowhere
near as advanced as it is today it's no
surprise there needed to be some kind of
representation of what was happening an
image that was easily recognizable that
offered some kind of explanation or
Solace regardless of whether it was true
or not the image chosen was the Grim
Reaper we can take a look at the
different aspects and what exactly they
may represent the skeleton is symbolic
of death or at least the natural cycle
when we die and eventually Decay the
Bones still remain the remnants of what
was once a living being the dark robes
were symbolic of the funeral process
more specifically the robes worn by
religious figures who conduct funeral
services so of all the weapons and tools
available why does the Grim Reaper carry
a scythe the Scythe is a tool used for
agriculture often to cut down grass or
grain the term reap refers to cutting or
harvesting a crop this is usually done
in the fall and is symbolic of the end
or the death of another year the Grim
Reaper is a harvester of souls taking
them from the end of their natural life
to the afterlife thus the connection to
the scythe with this creation of the
Grim Reaper you may be forgiven for
thinking this was some kind of evil or
malevolent figure that came with a bunch
of negative connotations however that
wasn't really the case nor the intention
the image was there as a symbol and to
offer Comfort at a time where death was
rampant and explanations as to why were
very limited death is a natural process
and it has been personified by every
culture for thousands of years in order
for us to understand the Grim Reaper or
the purpose of giving death a face we
should at least take a look at the
images that came before
in Greek mythology there are several
deities and Spirits associated with the
concept of death but one that we can
relate back to the Grim Reaper is
Thanatos the personification of natural
and gentle death a child of the Goddess
NYX Thanatos appears in a few stories
but you'll find him more commonly
mentioned in passing rather than
elaborated upon in any real detail as a
winged figure in dark robes who can also
be seen carrying a scythe or sickle it
is possible Thanatos may have provided
some inspiration for the Grim Reaper's
appearance
Hades by now I'm sure many of us are
familiar with as the king of the
underworld Hermes on the other hand is
not often regarded as a deity of death
but he did perform several roles
relating to the underworld being able to
Traverse so quickly naturally made him
the perfect messenger between the realm
of the living and the dead he would also
help in guiding souls to the underworld
married to Hades Persephone became a
deity Associated to the underworld and
death before she was a deity of spring
and nature her return from the
underworld every year during the Spring
is seen as a sign of immortality the
transition into Queen of the underworld
made her a deity similar to Hades where
people refused to use her name in fear
that it would invoke ill Fortune hercate
was the patron goddess of many things
and some of these included boundaries
and Crossroads which led to the idea
that she was able to unlock the gates
that separated the two different Realms
and so like Hermes she assumes the role
of ensuring the dead are able to travel
from one to the other as a gift for
siding with the Olympians during the
titanomachy Zeus gave hercate the
lampades these were torch-bearing nymphs
who travel with her carte to and from
the two different Realms ensuring the
path was well lit and unobstructed we
also can't forget individuals such as
Caron the ferryman who carries these
souls to the realm of the Dead Cerberus
who guards the gates of the underworld
ensuring that no one leaves without
permission the cares spirits so violent
death and the Arenas spirits of
vengeance
in Norse mythology you have hell Loki's
daughter who Reigns over the parts of
the underworld known as hell or hellheim
some of her depictions include a
two-toned face half white and half black
or blue sometimes the other half is made
up of exposed bone and decaying flesh
the two sides of her face are symbolic
of life and death remaining in the Norse
realm you also have the Valkyries female
winged figures who help guide the Fallen
Soldiers to the afterlife however they
do not take them to Hell's domain they
go to Valhalla or falconvenir sometimes
the Valkyries have wings and other times
they do not sometimes they ride horses
and other times they use horns full of
mead to make sure the Fallen Soldiers
follow them because if the a law of a
mysterious winged woman telling you that
the afterlife is just around the corner
wasn't enough then surely some alcohol
would seal the deal Odin himself also
has ties to death as he oversees those
in Valhalla taking half of those who
died in battle and making sure that they
are prepared for Ragnarok Norse
mythology as with many others divides
those who die into certain categories
and in charge of each one are different
gods and Spirits we know half of those
who died in battle are taken by Odin to
Valhalla the other half are taken by
freyja to Falk veneer the details and
purpose of this realm are fairly unclear
however it seems many agree falkmanir
was the alternative Realms of Valhalla
serving a similar function and ruled
over by freyja the biggest difference I
came Acro cross was the suggestion that
Odin and Freya preferred certain types
of warrior which is why they were hand
selected instead of just randomly
sending halfs of alhala and the rest of
falkman here freyja herself is the
goddess of fertility love beauty gold
and even War which in turn leads to
death it also explains why you have
depictions and stories of Freya that
describe her as this radiant Beauty but
there are also stories of her taking the
form of a battle hardened Valkyrie when
it comes to choosing the Fallen neither
one of those depictions is wrong they
simply reflect the different aspects of
a multi-faceted goddess
those who died at Sea would be collected
by the goddess ran ran and her husband
were the personifications of the sea
with their nine daughters being its
waves those who are unfortunate enough
to die at sea would be collected by Iran
in her giant net however some sources
suggest that this may not have
necessarily been an act of kindness the
Old Norse faran roughly translates to
mean theft robbery utter plunder and
thus we have the idea that Ran's actions
were far more malicious she would drown
those at Sea and using her net she would
collect their souls from the bottom of
the ocean
heading over to Norway we have what was
known as pester the plague hag the
plague hag was the personification of
the black death in Norway this elderly
woman wears a black hood and a dark red
skirt with her she carries a rake
wherever she goes pestilence follows
the story state that she travels the
countryside going from Farm to farm
spreading disease if you came across
pester in your village carrying her rake
that was a sign some would survive
however if she was sweeping away with
her broom unfortunately that meant your
entire Village was doomed one of the
ways pester would travel was by boat
many saw this as symbolic of how the
plague was spread and how the outbreak
made its way to Norway in the first
place through rat infested ships and
boats pester is one of the closest
comparisons we have to the Grim Reaper
in terms of purpose and time period
Celtic and Irish mythology have several
deities and Spirits associated with
death one of the most well-known being
the Morrigan the Morrigan is primarily
associated with war and fate this
branches into predicting the outcome of
a battle whether it's victory or
impending doom and death as a goddess of
battle the Morrigan sometimes takes the
form of a crow other times she can be
seen before the battle washing
blood-stained clothing those who see her
know that they have been fated to die
there are also times where she appears
to strike fear into the troops of her
enemies and to embolden and Inspire her
own there is the idea that the Morrigan
took pleasure in The Misfortune of
Fallen Soldiers and given the violent
nature of those dying many suggest that
the Morrigan inspire fired the concept
of the Banshee which came much later she
also has ties to the Austrian winter
Spirit perkter as well as Morgan lafaye
who is a fairly important character in
Arthurian law described as the wife of
the dagda the primary deity or King
within Irish and Celtic mythology the
Morrigan herself played a fairly
important role on occasion she can also
take the form of a triple goddess
appearing as three sisters however these
depictions are not very common
anku is a figure that appears in various
parts of Britain but is most common in
Ireland and Wales sometimes he appears
as nothing more than a shadow and other
times he is much closer to the Grim
Reaper a skeleton in Black robes wearing
a large hat that conceals most of his
face and wielding a scythe he drives a
large coach driven by black horses and
accompanied by Spectral companions his
primary role was to collect the souls of
those who had passed on in the hopes
that one day his debt would be paid and
he would be allowed entry into the
Afterlife his Origins can differ wildly
one story depicts him as a prince who
came across death during a hunting trip
he challenged death to see who could
kill a stag first death was Victorious
and with anku being a cruel Prince
feared by the people he cursed him to
roam the Earth as a ghoul for
eternity in another telling this was
then expanded to describe anku as a
servant of death charged with watching
over and protecting graveyards
collecting spirits who were lost in
guiding them in this telling anku became
more of a title or Duty each Parish had
what they called their own anku the last
person of the year to die assumed the
role of anku for their Parish until the
next year where a new person would be
selected some variations state that it
was actually the first person to die who
was selected the strangest of these
Origins depicts anku as the first child
of Adam and Eve
also known as the son of the sea was the
king of what was known as the other
world in Irish mythology part of the
Tour de danan Manon was the guardian of
the other world part of the Tour de
danan Manon was the guardian of the
other world which in Irish mythology was
a supernatural realm belonging to the
gods as well as the Dead the other world
is cloaked in mist and is invisible to
All Humans Manon rides a self-navigating
boat and was in charge of assigning
plots of land in the other world to the
remaining members of the Tour de danan
the Americas are also No Stranger when
it comes to the physical representation
of death Mexican folklore has Santa
Muerte which is shortened for Our Lady
of holy death over the last hundred
years or so she has become a far more
prominent figure with her own rapidly
growing cult and religious movement a
female skeletal figure dressed in a long
robe and carrying a scythe her attire in
general is much more colorful than the
Grim Reaper and I guess that comes down
to her being more of a celebratory
figure if we travel down to the likes of
Brazil Argentina Colombia and Paraguay
we have San Le Muerte otherwise known as
Saint death another skeletal figure
carrying a scythe but this time it's a
male figure both of these figures have
caused some free friction with the
Catholic Church which views them as
Pagan spirits and thus they should not
be mixed in with Christian belief San Le
moyete despite being frowned upon is
still considered a saint by Catholics in
the South American countries the same
can't be said for Our Lady of death in
Mexico whose belief essentially branched
off and became its own cult and religion
with many estimating anywhere between 10
to 20 million devoted followers
in some areas of Mexico and Guatemala
they tell stories of San basqualito the
king of the graveyard at this point in
time it should come as no surprise when
I tell you this King was a skeleton in
robes wearing a crown
a spirit we have spoken about in the
past is Baron Sandy who appears in
Haitian Voodoo and is associated with
death and fertility the spirits in
Haitian Voodoo are referred to as Loa
and these Spirits are divided into
families the gede family are the spirits
that embody the powers of death and
fertility the head of this family was
Baron Sandy who goes by many names
including Baron Le qua and baron
cemetiere the cross and the cemetery
Baron Sandy has an extremely distinct
appearance sometimes he is a skeleton
and his face is painted to resemble a
skull his top hat black tail coat and
fancy cane paint a fairly Dapper image
someone attending a party of sorts and
to an extent this is true his appearance
was meant to resemble a body that had
been prepared and dressed for a
haitian-style burial a time of mourning
but also celebration the celebration and
party atmosphere is greatly reflected in
Baron Sandy's personality and behavior
he is about as far from a solemn deity
of death as one could be never turning
down a chance to party Baron Sandy is
never too far away from a glass of rum
and a cigar the incessive smoking and
drinking is paired with his lust for
Mortal women and drug use just to
complete the Full House of debauchery
despite this Rowdy Behavior Baron Sandy
still performed all of his duties
greeting The Souls of the dead and
leading them to the underworld when
someone dies Baron Sandy digs their
grave and greets them if the baron
refuses to dig a grave then that person
cannot die even those who have been
afflicted by the worst type of hex or
those who have suffered horrendous
injuries may be able to cheat death if
the baron has taken a liking to them
this extends to him even being able to
cure Mortals of any wound or disease so
not only can he take life but he can
also restore it Baron Sandy was married
to Mama Brigitte who is just as
flamboyant and eccentric has her husband
she also has a taste for rum but chooses
to drink hers infused with chili peppers
Maman brijit protects tombs gravestones
cemeteries and any other place where the
dead May reside over the years she has
been heavily linked to the Irish deity
Brigid or again a member of the Tour de
danan who also has healing powers this
connection is why you may sometimes see
her depicted as a pale woman with red
hair as Haitian Voodoo is an
amalgamation of African vodun and
various European influences Maman brijit
was also seen as representing an often
depicted as several Saints including the
Irish Brigid of Kildare Mary Magdalene
and Saint Brigid this gives us two very
different depictions that contradict
each other the outspoken crude and
flamboyant individual who is often
portrayed in a sexualized manner similar
to Baron Sandy but then you also have
her shown as a saint given what there is
written about her behavior but also her
commitment to her duties one would
imagine the truth is somewhere in
between the baron and his wife had an
adopted son called geter Nebo a handsome
young man who suffered a violent and
tragic death the baron and his wife
adopted him and in joining their family
he became the patron saint for those who
died too early he shares many of the
traits and behaviors of his adopted
parents but is easily recognized by the
bottle of white rum that he carries that
has been infused with medicinal herbs
get an ebo was considered a great healer
as well as the voice for spirits that
had yet to be reclaimed for passage to
the afterlife or the lower World in
Haitian voodoo
in Japan there is the Izanagi and
izinami the brother and sister deities
associated with creation but also death
the first Gods created these two Divine
beings and charged them with creating
the very first land mass the connection
to death comes when is an army died and
Izanagi began his journey to yomi or the
underworld to find his wife when Izanagi
found his wife she was hidden by the
Shadows he pleaded for her to return but
this wasn't possible as she had eaten
the food of the underworld and so her
place amongst the dead had already been
decided izan Army would still try and
ask for permission to leave in the
morning while she slept Izanagi using
his comb as a torch was finally able to
glance upon his wife and what he saw
petrified him the once beautiful is an
army was covered in maggots her body
ravaged and her flesh rotting so given
that Izanagi had traveled all the way to
the underworld to find his lost wife he
then did The Honorable thing he ran for
his life as fast as he could abandoning
his no longer attractive wife and
sealing the entrance to the underworld
shut with a very very large Boulder izan
Army gave Chase sending the spirits of
the Dead to find her husband however
with the entrance sealed the land of the
living was now separated from the land
of the dead hence the separation between
Izanagi life and is an army death
the once goddess of creation screamed
for her husband to return otherwise
threatening to destroy 1 000 Souls of
the living a day Izanagi responded by
saying he would then give life to
1500 Souls every day
enma is the figure who rules over hell
and appears in various mythologies
across southeast Asia his name changes
depending on the form of Buddhism we are
discussing and in Japanese Buddhism the
name is enma he rules over the kings of
hell and decides whether one's sins were
enough to condemn them to Eternal
punishment this is a figure we can cover
in some more detail when we head over to
China
the Shinigami are spirits I'm sure some
people may be familiar with Shinigami
translates to mean death God or Reaper
in English these Spirits beckon and call
out to humans bringing them closer to
their demise at times is an army has
been compared and categorized as a class
of Shinigami stories from the Edo period
discuss these deities of death and their
ability to possess humans some of these
Spirits are described as having bad
intent and some state that the Shinigami
chooses a person based on the person's
intent these acts and feelings exist
inside of the person and so the
possession merely removes the barriers
that stop them from axing them out
whether it's committing suicide murder
or other heinous crimes it's clear the
Shinigami provided some with a reason or
an explanation as to why these acts
occur to some it may have even been an
excuse
China in general has an insane amount of
deity so covering all of them would be
well insanity but seeing as we already
discussed at enma we can take a look at
his Chinese counterpart Yama or in this
case King Yan going by dozens of names
King yarn ruled over the realm of the
Dead in Chinese mythology here hell is
divided up and ruled over by 10
different Kings overseeing these Kings
we have King Yan these kings are in
charge of what is normally referred to
as the 8 or 10 courts of Hell Spirits
passing through these courts are judged
by Yan based on the actions whilst alive
once he had decided their fate they
continue traveling through hell until
they reach the part of hell that serves
as punishment for their crime King Yan
often appears as an angry red face the
bearded man towering above all of those
around him
guarding the underworld we have the very
strange Duo of ox head and horse face
their names don't leave much to the
imagination two men one with an ox head
and the other a horse face that doesn't
make it any less of a terrifying
experience given they are the first two
one encounters when entering the
underworld these two absolute mad Lads
had three main roles to stop Souls from
trying to escape the underworld to
capture and escort new souls to the
underworld to stand before the courts of
Hell lastly they acted as Messengers to
the kings of Hell one story they do
appear in which is definitely on my list
of future projects is Journey to the
West
the last of these three Chinese Legends
I've chosen to cover today is Meng Poe
the goddess of forgetfulness mengpo
resides in the course of hell where
souls go when they are ready to be
reincarnated once they arrive and cross
the bridge of forgetfulness mengpo
serves them the five flavored tea of
forgetfulness which essentially wipes
all of their memories and allows them to
reincarnate into their new life without
any fear or burdens from the previous
one this is also seen as purging the
soul of any previous sin allowing for a
clean slate and the cycle to start over
mengpo's story is one of grief and
sadness when her husband died she took
all of this pain into the Afterlife and
found herself unable to reincarnate
because she could never let go and so
she decided to to relieve the pain of
the other spirits in the Underworld
allowing them to do what she could never
and start over there are some stories of
individuals who refuse to drink the tea
and when they began their new lives
memories flooded back to them and so you
have strange events such as newborn
children speaking fluently because they
remembered how mengpo assumes the form
of an elderly woman with old lady Meng
being just one of the many names she
went by
Egyptian mythology like many others has
several deities and spirits of death
Anubis is a deity who played a very
important role throughout someone's
entire journey into the Afterlife this
included the mummification and embalming
process the protection of Graves and
cemeteries and The Guiding of souls to
the underworld when a soul is ready to
pass the threshold of the living to the
afterlife they are Guided by Anubis
where one's heart is then weighed
against a feather to see if you are
worthy of entering the underworld this
process is also carried out by Anubis
another deity that takes part in this
process is Amit the Devourer of the Dead
some of you may also know a meat as that
very weird looking thing from Moon
Knight Amit was made up of the three
animals the Egyptians feared most the
head of a crocodile the front legs and
upper body of a lion and the lower body
of a hippopotamus a fairly strange
combination but given all three animals
were manises Anna meets primary job was
eating those Unworthy of the afterlife
it does start to make sense if one's
heart weighed the same or less than the
feather your soul was deemed as pure and
you were able to continue your journey
to Osiris and the immortality of the
Underworld for those whose Hearts
weighed more than the feather their
Journey to the underworld ended here
they were devoured by a meat where they
would never rest and be forced to stand
in a lake of fire this was often equated
to dying a second time and being denied
the peace that comes with the after life
the ancient Egyptians were terrified of
a meat and not just because of her
appearance because of everything she
represented
Osiris was a god of Agriculture and
fertility but this soon changed to
include the dead resurrection and the
afterlife after a feud with his brother
set Osiris was killed and chopped into
14 pieces scattered around Egypt
eventually these pieces would be found
and buried together giving Osiris a
second chance resurrected as the judge
and King of the underworld
as we've seen today the vast majority of
spirits or deities associated with death
are not necessarily evil death is a very
common fear and every culture creates
its own stories as a way to explain and
essentially deal with the idea that
death is something we must all face
eventually
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign